all right we want to bring in we're
actually really excited it is official
we're hitting the road and next week
we'll be on the ground in Singapore of
course to cover all the latest from
president Trump's historic and
consequential talks with the North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un and tonight
were just days away from direct talks
between the United States of America and
North Korea something that many thought
was totally completely impossible a
scenario that Obama and Kerry and
Clinton and others and all these friends
on the Left they could only dream of and
here's what the president is saying
about what could be one of the most
significant summits in modern history
take a look I've been preparing all my
life I always believed in preparation
but I've been preparing all my life you
know these one-week preparations they
don't work just ask Hillary what
happened to her in the debate so I've
been preparing for this all my life yeah
he has and by the way he reminded
everybody remember the debates with
Hillary also our Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo who's been working very hard on
all of this he weighed in let's take a
look at that the fact that our two
leaders are coming to the table shows
that the two sides are very serious the
diplomatic model used to date is
different from past efforts our efforts
give us hope that we can find real
success for past efforts have fallen
short President Trump is hopeful but
he's also going into the summit with his
eyes wide open we've seen how many
inadequate agreements have been struck
in the past and you can be sure the
President Trump will not stand for a bad
deal all right how do we get to this
point all right let's go back little
history lesson Hannity history lesson we
start in the 90s and President Bill
Clinton it was a good deal for the
American people remember that when he
met with the North Korean dictator at
the time Kim Jong Un's father Kim
jong-il
well Clinton then promised this was a
good agreement for the American people
they're not going to get nuclear weapons
and he paid billions of dollars in
energy subsidies and made concessions
and somehow sucking up and bribing
dictators would make for world peace
didn't work out but you may remember
this this is a good deal for the United
States
North Korea will freeze and then
dismantle its nuclear program South
Korea and our other allies will be
better protected the entire world will
be safer as we slow the spread of
nuclear weapons South Korea with support
from Japan and other nations will bear
most of the cost of providing North
Korea with fuel to make up for the
nuclear energy it is losing and they
will pay for an alternative power system
for North Korea that will allow them to
produce electricity while making it much
harder for them to produce nuclear
weapons the United States and
international inspectors will carefully
monitor North Korea to make sure it
keeps its commitments only as it does so
will North Korea fully join the
community of nations now Bill Clinton he
was dead wrong well Korea successfully
developed a nuclear weapons program and
under eight years of the former
President Obama while his weak and
feckless leadership while Kim Jong Un's
actions became progressively more
aggressive and more hostile and
President Obama left Trump with
unfettered international disaster after
disaster this is just one in fact when
President Trump took office in 2017 the
situation in North Korea
was at a boiling point remember Kim
jong-un shooting long-range missiles
over Japan threatening to blow up whaam
and conducting numerous underground
tests of nuclear weapons but after eight
years of weak pathetic spineless
leadership under Obama things have
changed and President Trump actually
responded you may remember this Korea
best not make any more threats to the
United States they will be met with fire
fury and frankly power the likes of
which this world has never seen before
frankly the people that were questioning
that statement was it too tough maybe it
wasn't tough enough they've been doing
this to our country for a long
for many years and it's about time that
somebody stuck up for the people of this
country and for the people of other
countries and what they've been getting
away with is a tragedy and it can't be
allowed if anything happens to Guam
there's going to be big big trouble in
North Korea he does anything with
respect to Guam or anyplace else that's
an American territory for an American
ally he will truly regret it and he will
regret it fast
Rocketman is on a suicide mission for
himself and for his regime now of course
the president then backed up his tough
rhetoric with action and he sent
multiple Carrier Strike groups to the
region he conducted numerous military
drills ramped up devastating sanctions
against North Korea and of course put a
lot of pressure on North Korea's biggest
ally China and he forged a great
relationship with the Chinese president
what this is called these words our
peace drew strength and by the way it
said your mainstream corrupt destroyed
Trump media into literally a hysterical
fit okay you can't make this up take a
look the idea of a nuclear showdown with
North Korea keeps you up at night I
would recommend deleting your Twitter
app he is not merely being cavalier with
a threat about nuclear war he's being
Cavalier in a way that it makes him seem
demented these are the messages from a
person who is not well from a leader who
is not fit for office president Trump is
goading Kim jong-un to test a nuclear
missile again to prove its reliability
to show him wrong and fundamentally I
think it comes across as to
kindergarteners who are jostling each
other except that each has nuclear
weapons after a hundred thousand
Americans die after a nuclear holocaust
or after a million die inside that's
where we are this is not an exaggeration
Trump's comments about nuclear weapons
have experts worried he could literally
inadvertently trigger a catastrophe of
course we now know for certain the media
is absolutely wrong they were wrong they
are wrong and in the interim North Korea
halted their nuclear tests
all ICBM tests done they returned three
American hostages they agreed to discuss
now the complete D nuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula in exchange for no
concessions remember he crossed over the
DMZ into the arms of the South Korean
president and he dismantled one of his
nuclear test sites and despite the
president's diplomatic progress your
media is still hating doubting and sadly
many even actively rooting for failure
this would be great for the world or
kids or grandkids now take a look at the
highly deranged MSNBC conspiracy host
questioning Trump's preparedness for the
upcoming summit what's this we do have
to point out the president was critical
that when we played that clip of him
talking about being prepared for the
North Korea summit we didn't say we
didn't add what he said at the end and
he was critical and he said I've been
preparing all my life I'd love to know
mr. president when was that when you
appeared in Playboy softcore porn movie
was it when you bodyslam Vince McMahon
the head of the World Wrestling
Federation or was it when you were
leaking information when you were
disguising yourself as your own PR guy
talking to tabloids about what a great
lover you were take a look at this cover
from The Economist showing the president
in the place of Miley Cyrus you know
that infamous video wrecking ball
accompanied with the headline quote even
if Donald Trump strikes a deal with
North Korea his foreign policy will harm
America in the world even if he does it
all right that's rooting for failure and
while the media tries to bash the
president at every turn they can't help
themselves
he has a lot of really important
diplomacy to tackle now we're gonna have
a lot more tonight on the upcoming talks
in Singapore throughout the show we will
be broadcasting there all next week but
first today president Trump he landed in
Quebec in Canada to meet world leaders
at the annual g7 summit tensions were
running high ahead of the meeting after
President Trump announced plans to
tackle some of the unfair trading
international practices with retaliatory
tariffs he wants free and fair trade and
last night the president called on
Canada you pulled them out on Twitter
writing quote Prime Minister Trudeau is
being so indignant bringing up the
relationship that the US and Canada had
over the many years and all sorts of
other things but he doesn't bring up the
fact that they charge up to 300% Andheri
hurting our farmers killing our
agriculture and French president McCrone
responded on Twitter calling the
president quote isolated and today
here's what Trump had to say about what
could be a very tense but interesting g7
Trump summit take a look if we're unable
to make a deal will terminate NAFTA
we'll have a better deal if we are
unable to make a deal we will be a
better off right now we are not going to
live with the deals the way they are
European Union treats us very unfairly
Canada very unfairly Mexico very
unfairly with that being said I think
we'll probably very easily make a deal
well the president is busy doing what he
does best and that's negotiating I know
if I asked him to come on the show he'll
say I'll give you five I'll say 15 how
about six I'll give you 14 and that's
what President Trump does now the media
has been very busy doing what they do
best spreading anti Trump it's real
copious amounts of fake news especially
true over it NBC news just take a look
at how absolutely disgusting this clip
is where NBC hosts are trashing the
women in the president's life this is so
deranged and off the rails you can't
even make it up let me ask you I mean
you know more about the Trump women
that's not my family than anyone what do
they do on a day like today are they
just the most stoic human beings are
they numb are they dead inside are they
paid off I mean what's their deal yes
yes and yes but I I think they do not
see president Trump the way that all of
us see president Trump they have such a
distorted image of who he is that they
don't they don't have the kind of
reaction that we do it's it's almost
some sort of trick but they're mothers
now I mean what kind of I mean then they
seem very raising nice kids I mean what
how do they wall at all dead inside and
ELAC are you proud of this this is your
network really is that news to you now
what about this clip by the way from
your morning anchor liberal Joe Amica
and by the way Andy lack are you
really proud of this bizarre conspiracy
that cheese now while pawning off his
news on your so-called news network
here you go I hope you love it I'll tell
you a couple of things first of all the
hypocrisy is astounding because I know
someone who spoke to Donald Trump
recently about life in the White House
and Donald Trump's biggest complaint was
that he's not allowed to watch porn in
the White House he's upset that he can't
watch porn in the White House they have
those you know 1 900 numbers block 2
which must be a disappointment I'm not
really sure but that's it just sort of
flies in the face of all of this
now of course NBC News is far from being
the only news outlet with their extreme
bias against the president many in the
media well they've been going after
yours truly all week because of a
monologue I did earlier in the week and
all I did was highlight a sad example of
what is a two-tiered justice system in
this country we don't have equal justice
under the law we have one system of
justice for the Clintons and one for the
rest of us and I was obviously being
sarcastic and making a comparison I said
what if I said that those that robert
muller has requested their foes from
what if i said it's a bad idea
kidding i said all sorts of caveats what
if they follow hillary clinton's lead
what if in fact they decided to delete
their emails wipe away all evidence acid
wash and bleach pit the hard drives on
those phones and then smash him up into
itsy-bitsy pieces with hammers they were
more mad at me than they actually were
at hillary for actually doing these
things here's a taste of how the media
distorted these commas sean hannity is
now literally telling potential
witnesses and subjects in the Malheur
probe to destroy the evidence and hammer
their phones into pieces the Hannity's
defenders may call that sarcasm or
poetic license but words are words sean
hannity lives off his words and we all
know they have a huge
impact if anyone actually does what Sean
Hannity says there they'd be committing
a crime what Sean Hannity admitted to it
actually was enticing people to do and
asking them to do was to destroy
evidence which is a violation of the
witness tampering statute no responsible
person on television no responsible
so-called journalists should be
advocating for people to destroy
evidence in a serious federal
investigation I don't think that we'll
see him prosecuted federal prosecutors
give people a very wide berth on First
Amendment related conduct and so unless
there's something more specific to link
it up I think that this will be what we
often categorize as awful but lawful
conduct listen if he's out there
advocating for Muller's witnesses to
obstruct justice then maybe the Moller
speak to him and ask him where the idea
come from have you spoken to the
president about this did the president
tell you to say this knowing Moeller I
think he's not going to light that fire
under someone who gets free airtime
every day but but what angle what angle
would be to say yeah look I'm going to
I'm going to a judge and I'm gonna have
you see I'm gonna have you cease and
desist this activity on national
television secondly I want to talk to
you and see if Trump has gotten this
idea from you or vice-versa
cease and desist call me into moterz
office the idea came from me I can't
believe how stupid some of you people
are that's supposedly work in this
business